so we're going to start today with our
sort of first major results from the
2022 midterms these are primary results
and the big picture so far is relatively
unremarkable but pretty good for donald
trump in terms of his so-called track
record in endorsing people now we'll
talk about a bias to incumbency and all
these different things as we get further
in but at least for today let's start
with the few races where we had uh
elections yesterday and see what
takeaways there are in indiana there was
the republican primary in the ninth
congressional district uh not a
particularly prominent race aaron
hoochin won there relatively easily over
mike cidrell
but more interestingly and a lot of
attention paid to this race so far in
the ohio us senate republican primary
j.d vance won now it's not jp
it's not j.d mandel as donald trump
claimed to endorse at his rally over the
weekend not even knowing who he endorsed
it's jd
vance jd vance winning by about seven
points over josh mandel this is the
first sort of signal about trump's
endorsement power and we can argue it's
not really the perfect example
because there were so many different
people who endorsed jd vance prominent
republicans marjorie taylor greene and
matt gates and many others but
regardless this is a situation where jd
vance was uh i believe fourth in the
polls at the point at which donald trump
endorsed him and he ultimately won 31 to
24
over josh mandel so that is one
interesting race now remember
uh this is the one where trump didn't
even really seem to know who he endorsed
remember this from over the weekend
that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for one race you know we've
endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right jd mandel
and he's doing great yeah uh we've
endorsed uh jp right is that who it was
uh but this is important because the
mega world or i'm hearing it now
pronounced maga by many people
including donald trump jr they're
jumping all over this and saying trump's
endorsement reigns supreme it is the
most important thing uh denouncer
distance from trump at your own peril
here is a hopped up don jr last night
shot out of a cannon making this point
remember that republicans because
there's far too many of you that forget
that and you'd rather cater to the media
the leftists the other weak republicans
so that you can be loved and invited to
the cool person party in dc
no more folks
the maga movement is a live and well and
we're witnessing it tonight
congratulations jd i know you're going
to make us proud of the us senate
right okay so there's don jr with a shot
across the bow at anybody thinking of uh
going with the non-trump candidate i
guess or um undervaluing the important
of uh donald trump's endorsement now
remember that jd vance at one point said
that he was going back and forth as to
whether trump is america's hitler that's
what jd vance used to say he then had a
change of heart i guess and he groveled
a lot uh and donald trump ultimately did
endorse him now going back to the
results on the democratic side tim ryan
has won now tim ryan's a member of the
house currently he's been a guest on
this show before i think he's a good guy
he's a smart guy he's an impassioned
speaker for me
this is an extraordinarily important
race and of course
it is now tim ryan versus jd vance
i'm supporting tim ryan uh we will see
if we get debates there i would love to
cover those debates but this is a
particularly great race to get involved
in ryan easily winning the primary with
73 of the vote against uh two pr two
main opponents and that's good news now
continuing with the trump impact
over in the ninth congressional district
in ohio
as of this moment when we are taping
today's show it has not yet been called
but j.r majewski is in the lead now j.r
majewski is trump endorsed he was also a
guest on this program a few weeks ago he
was a sort of
kind of reasonable trumpist although he
still says trump won
and that 2020 was stolen and all of that
stuff but if indeed j.r majewski
prevails it will be another win for
donald trump's endorsement record to the
extent that uh it matters on the
democratic side disappointing to many
another attempt by nina turner
in the 11th congressional district this
is the democratic primary in ohio 11th
congressional district nina turner
losing very badly to chantal brown
now you might remember that in 2021
there was a special election between
these same candidates chantal brown and
nina turner
and in 2021 nina turner lost by 6
50 to 44. there was the hope among many
that this time around with nina turner
having more name recognition
she would be able to pull this off she
did not she actually lost by nearly 30
points and uh sort of alluded
last night that nina turner is running
for president in 2024
so uh
i'm not going to do my analysis again of
nina turner's loss i did it in 2021 and
many of you agreed with it some of you
didn't and were angry with me uh but the
analysis is the same an even bigger loss
at this point in time and at this point
it doesn't even seem prudent to comment
on nina turner for president uh a lot a
lot of things have to happen between now
and then but chantal brown uh with a
very very strong victory there
uh 13 congressional 13th congressional
district republican primary in ohio
madison gilbert won there but not by
that much
in the ohio gubernatorial primary uh
mike dewine winning relatively easily
there
and some other races that i don't think
are particularly interesting to most in
our audience there was a nashville
district attorney democratic primary i
know
uh of no one in my audience who was
paying attention to that one just not
that it doesn't matter it's just a a
very very local race so we're keeping an
eye on a number of these races the
pennsylvania
senate race is very important that one
could ultimately decide who controls the
senate in 2023 republicans or democrats
tonight at 7 30 p.m eastern the
republicans running for pennsylvania
senate will be debating that includes
mehmet oz dave mccormick
and others and others and we'll be live
with that on youtube twitch and facebook
so i hope you will join me there and
many more primaries coming in may
all of which we will cover all right the
right wing and republicans are
pretending
that the leak of the supreme court
decision on abortion which we discussed
yesterday is worse than the trump
riot coup
insurrection of january 6 2021.
we knew they were going to do this and
they are axios uh with a very
interesting um uh three-page document
they obtained the three-page memo about
the messaging that republicans want
on this uh issue
and their focus is
the leak is terrible the leak is a crime
although they can't tell us what law was
broken and it's an absolute travesty
not that abortion rights are now going
to be able to be
brutally curtailed but that we learned
about this decision a few weeks early
and you can check out this document
axios linking to it um and they are
uh focusing in
on this issue of the leak is really the
problem and we have a bunch of uh
examples of this which i'm going to play
for you now
again the real issue here is activist
judges the right loves to say oh
democrats put up activist judges who
will legislate from the bench
all of trump's picks paid lip service
during their confirmation hearings to
the supreme court to i respect precedent
president's important and roe v wade is
is the is precedent right now and then
as far as we know from the draft
document they're all voting to overturn
precedent that's activist judicial uh
that is judicial activism uh without a
doubt but republicans want to focus on
oh the leak the leak the leak we'll look
at some clips ted cruz never uh finds a
cynical opportunity to uh make news when
he sees it he seizes those opportunities
here he is saying this was probably some
left-wing law clerk this is a travesty
draft opinion that was leaked last night
i have to say it is utterly stunning
that
anyone at the court would leak a draft
opinion uh you know this is ted cruz by
the way he has this whole
sincere concern
uh
uh sort of posture down pat one hand in
the pocket
the other hand kind of signaling and
using this kind of fake sincere voice
100 years of our nation's history this
has never happened
and
now it's not true it's never happened it
actually happened with the roe v wade
decision in the 70s but who's going to
let the facts get in the way of a good
story i am appalled right this is the
most egregious breach of trust
at the supreme court that has ever
happened
ever presumably some left-wing law clerk
angry at the direction the court is
going decided to betray his or her
obligation the trust
that clerk owed to his or her justice
and to the court the word presumably
doing some pretty heavy lifting there no
information about who leaked this so far
then ted cruz continued the rounds and
went on fox news where he said he wants
the person who leaked this serving real
jail time reason it was leaked
is some left-wing presumably law clerk
presumably wanted to put political
pressure on the five justices that
presumably are in the majority right now
they wanted to put heat and they wanted
to invoke politics to try to get them to
change their vote and and by the way if
if that left-wing law clerk succeeds it
will be the most grotesque
politicization of the supreme court in
the history of our nation you mentioned
an fbi investigation i hope there is a
serious one and i hope whoever is
responsible for this not only is fired
instantly but is prosecuted and serves
real jail time for violating the
confidences of the supreme court now
still unable to articulate an actual
crime that was committed then we go to
the daily wire host michael knowles
whose program i've appeared on he says
this he just straight up says this is
worse than the trump riots
absolutely
earth-shattering stuff and i won't let
the libs get me down they're trying to
gum this up they're trying to pressure
the conservatives to switch
what the conservatives need to do right
now
just come out with the opinion
i don't know if it's in its final draft
this goes all the way back to february
so presumably it's in much better shape
come out with the opinion
if the opinion is substantially
different
from this draft
then we will know that the libs
have succeeded
at pressuring at threatening violence
that's really what this is about right
you you whip up all of the riots you're
gonna have a whole lot of mostly
peaceful demonstrations coming out with
molotov cocktails and rocks and all the
rest of it
and it will make a mockery of our system
of government i never want to hear about
the the norms
our norms are sacred cherished
democratic norms i don't want to hear it
from the left anymore i never want to
hear the stupid phrase january 6th this
is
so much more egregious an attack on our
democracy than january 6th ever was it's
not even comparable yeah a decision
leaking a few weeks early is worse than
the trump riots with 700 plus alleged
criminals then we go over to judge
jeanine she also wants jail time doesn't
know what the crime is but jail time she
wants quickly they were on opposite
sides so whoever leaked this we have to
find out who the person is and and and
charge them with a crime i don't know
what the crime would be whether it's
some kind of fraud on government
property i heard there's a statute fraud
on a government that's very broad that
could include this kind of yeah that's
not going to work janine sorry
leaking a decision a few weeks early you
could get fired you're definitely not
doing what you're supposed to be doing
in your job at the supreme court i don't
doubt that but this is an issue for the
supreme court as an employer to figure
out fraud on government property give me
a break uh greg gutfeld who's i guess a
comedian he took a different approach
where he had what i guess counts as
comedy as a response to this republican
presidents and republican senators and
you nominate conservative judges then
you will get to overturn roe v wade so
now both sides are going to have to deal
with the fallout on it yeah you know
joey i think you know what scares me
about this decision it's obviously going
to target the truly marginalized and i
speak of pregnant men um what are your
thoughts see how funny that is guys
that's comedy
the right is getting better at comedy
and it's really scaring us on the left
and then lastly right wing kind of uh i
don't even know if she's an actress
right-wing person jillian anderson
tweeting leaking a supreme court opinion
is far worse than anything that happened
on january sixth and of course
it's not uh this is one approach and
then after the break we're going to talk
about
they're not going to stop with just
abortion that's coming up later find me
on twitter at deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
i want to look today at some really
great work being done by our friend
jesse dollamore some of you might
remember last summer jesse filled in for
me when i was away and he actually went
down to the supreme court yesterday and
spoke to a variety of different
demonstrators and activists and
protesters and you know i'm kind of
using all these different terms because
there it was a combination of different
types of folks and i want to look at a
couple of conversations he had the first
one starting with an anti-choice
protester
who seemed to have been
um uh hesitant to really identify who he
was with it's a very interesting and
cringe-worthy conversation so let's
start there jesse doing a really good
job and you can check out his youtube
channel uh podcast let's just jump right
into this first interview that he did
these are the types of folks that we are
up against here and understand that they
don't care about double standards they
don't care about hypocrisy they care
about only the outcomes and they'll
justify anything to get to those
outcomes
what's your name colton
what uh what are you doing out here
today
uh i'm gonna be out here uh doing
interviews just like you about this as
soon as my camera guy gets here but uh i
believe that the sanctity of life should
be protected
and the supreme court shouldn't be
politicized and the fact that
this
opinion was released
the leak is the issue
not the
ruling i'm okay with the ruling
but the leak
that comes out so early that just shows
how politicized this is did you know
that the the original roe ruling was
also leaked in 1973 which overturned a
few justices opinions
yeah so
there was
it's like jesse is visibly flummoxed
because
the guy doesn't even seem to realize the
double standard well i'm concerned with
the leak well roe v wade in 73 also
leaked right yeah but that overturned
justice's opinions wait so but so what
huh if this happens
time after time after time in the adults
of the supreme court in the history of
the supreme court why is this why is it
such an outrageous
because they're trying to intimidate the
justices to overturn their opinions
how how does it equate how does it map
on to intimidation of the justice
by the public opinion threatening the
lies last night they were out here
chanting effelito this thing about the
lives of the justices are being
threatened is so absurd supreme court
justices have great security the supreme
court has great security no nobody's
life is in jeopardy here
are you are you witnessing the same
thing i am relative to what is
aggressive
and merely witnessing and empower
prayer visuals and uh speeches
[Music]
we have the majority of the people over
here who are uh pro-choice
[Music]
this kid's just very confused it's i
mean
heavy weight has got to go
well the majority of the people on this
side is pro-choice yes there are some
pro-life people over there
who do you work for i'm not going to say
you're not going to say okay
so why was it you ditched the uh the
the proud boy motif when when i ask you
to ask questions proud boy thank you
yeah you know the hat and the
the whole the whole little thing you got
going on oh the project veritas hat yeah
yeah not not proud fascist enabler no
really
you wanna you're either you're in a
agreement with stripping 50 years of
precedent and human increasing civil
rights of women i am agreeing with uh
protecting the life of the unborn which
murdered over 63 million unborn children
so are you for the child tax credit
i am four are you for the child tax
credit sir this is a completely
different uh are you for increased snap
benefits this is a completely different
argument it's kind of not actually i
mean this is one of the big things
authoritarian clamp down on medical
choices
but then absolutely ignoring what should
be
a responsibility once you force someone
to have a child because if 80 000
people are born into poverty
um
do you how are you going to fund are you
mad the increaser industry
that cancer industry the organizations
that fight against cancer are you
against them because they don't fight
against diabetes
no they're no they're saying it's cause
and effect right but the thing is
fighting cancer doesn't cause diabetes
fighting diabetes doesn't cause cancer
that i'm aware of so
really good job but by jesse here
exposing this guy um and then here's
another one and this is just an example
again of the sort of like people that
are ancillary and attached to this
anti-choice movement
so first this is a guy i'm going to try
to see what it's shirt i want to
describe to you what his shirt actually
says because it's kind of a good fan
jesse's uh hand it seems to be saying
gay bisexual transgender morals
something than animals the national zoo
it this is this is very weaponized stuff
national zoo
in 1990
[Music]
in 1990 these girls raped the skirt
raped these girls from school
we took nine girls down to national zoo
trying to find out if they have any
homosexual animals
national zoos they didn't have more than
400 different species of mammals animals
exotic animals and nationalism but they
noticed that i'm a homosexual once you
come out of nashville
i guess this guy is saying there's a
it's a big red flag for him that a zoo
didn't have any gay animals but then he
goes out goes out in the world and
there's gay people this is pretty deep
stuff guys
according to the bible lesbian women are
called fine and the men are called dogs
because they dog like men
so
so you you take no issue with wearing
hate speech on your shirt or just about
bigotry hatred
i said you're a bigot
right i am yeah you are yeah right i am
okay
you gotta be a bigger satanic people
like that right all right so the guy
welcoming the label of a bigot
really great stuff by jesse and he
speaks to a number of different people i
encourage encourage you to check it out
but again it goes back to when we talk
about the big lie trump really won 2020.
you go and you have a conversation with
these people and you realize these
people are gone to quote alex jones how
there's no bringing them back and then
on abortion you go to the supreme court
you talk to some of these folks and you
realize
there's no bringing these people back
at least not in any sensible reasonable
amount of time great job by jesse we're
really up against it here uh i want to
address one of the other stories that
now is going to be a really big story in
the wake of this leaked supreme court
decision that will as far as we know
overturn roe v wade
there immediately were gatherings of
protesters both on the pro-choice and
anti-choice side at the supreme court
and elsewhere as we just saw
uh
protesters on both sides have been
mostly peaceful and anecdotally we have
seen
instances of individuals allegedly
escalating there have been some little
brawls between the two camps and police
have gotten involved at this point i
can't say more than that
but there is definitely the potential
that we will see continued or growing
unrest surrounding this decision and the
unrest may come from any side i condemn
violence i'm against violence now that
we've gotten that out of the way
the right is acting as though
it is the pro-choice left that is
uniquely and particularly violent
physically in this political
disagreement and that is a lie the
history
of anti-abortion
violence is abhorrent and you can easily
google this and find endless examples
cnn has one good article about this
there have been more than 200 bombings
and arson attacks at facilities that
offer abortion services
you could argue that that's terrorism
it's meant to terrorize as a group those
who have or might someday seek abortion
services
um
the first reported clinic arson was in
76 just after roe v wade wow what a
shocker there were clinic bombings in 78
and 84. in the 90s it escalated even
more dr david gunn was shot and killed
in pensacola florida by a gunman against
abortion
dr john bayard britain and his security
escort were shot and killed in front of
a pensacola clinic
clinic employees shannon
lowney and leanne nichols were shot and
killed in brookline massachusetts
off-duty police officer robert sanderson
was killed in the bombing of a
birmingham alabama
clinic
a sniper killed dr barnett slepian in
amherst new york and famously famously
an anti-abortion gunman killed 67 year
old george tiller in wichita kansas in
2009. that's a story we covered at the
time our show was on the air
um he was he was killed he was an
abortion clinic director so these are
extraordinarily
violent folks who have been willing to
do all sorts of violence you could argue
it's also violence to show up and
intimidate people going in for medical
services as they've done all over the
country
and yet you have all of these uh people
on the right acting as though
the right that is against abortion is
completely peaceful um there is one
tweet here
from who is this from
this is from rebecca monsoor who's the
senior editor of breitbart news who said
quote the freakout you were witnessing
from the left is very instructive when
roe was handed down 49 years ago
pro-lifers didn't riot didn't call for
the supreme court to be burned down
didn't threaten the lives of justices
and didn't try to stack the court well
they did 200 bombings and attacks of
abortion clinics then uh jill
philippovic who's a writer lawyer and
author tweeted actually since roe was
handed down 49 years ago so-called
pro-lifers have committed 11 murders 26
attempted murders 4 kidnappings 42
bombings
667 bomb threats 100 butyric acid
attacks 189 arsons
on and on and on
they are violent they are violent don't
let them trick you into thinking that it
is the pro-choice left that is the
violent group now
could either could individuals on either
side anecdotally commit violence in the
next few days sure and i'm against it
and they should be
arrested if they commit a crime or or
are believed to have committed a crime
and they should be uh charged and
prosecuted absolutely both sides don't
care who it is but the historical record
is the violence comes from the
anti-choice side we'll have these clips
and tweets on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show so we're continuing our
conversations with a number of different
republicans running in the 2022 midterm
elections today we're going to be
speaking with john gibbs john gibbs is a
trump endorsed republican the former
assistant secretary for community
planning and development at hud in the
trump administration and is running in
michigan's third congressional district
the incumbent in that race is peter
meyer uh it's great to have you on john
i really appreciate your time
thanks for having me on david i really
appreciate it so let's start with
something really easy just to to kind of
get started um
donald trump took a a a bit of issue
with your opponent's last name having a
silent j in it he seemed not to like
that at a recent rally you take no issue
with the spelling of your opponent's
name right
well i think the difference is i'm from
michigan and so we grew up seeing the
supermarket chain and whatnot so we're
really used to it but i can see how
someone who's not from here like
president trump would not be familiar
with that spelling or how i pronounce it
so you know that's just how i look at it
beautiful okay so um
i want to start with
what is leading you to run most people
who choose to run say well to some
degree uh i mean people in media and
people in politics in a sense there's a
narcissistic element right like if
you're in media and you want to talk you
have to on some level think what i'm
saying is at least as interesting as
what anybody else is going to have to
say and if you're going to run for for
office to some degree
you believe you can do a better job than
the person that's there
so tell me about that what problems do
you see that you think you can fix
um well i mean the list goes on and on
but we have inflation which is causing
gas prices to you know skyrocket through
the roof we have
empty shelves at stores and you have
high prices at grocery stores as well
for basic things like chicken or pork
chops whatever it might be this is
having a huge impact on the middle class
and working class folks especially the
poor and minorities really got to step
up and do something about this so um and
that's just domestically that doesn't
talk about afghanistan and the botched
patrol and ukraine and what's going on
there so i think there's just a very
long list of issues that we need to
address and i think um very humbly based
on my experience in dc for four years in
our administration i got to learn the
machinery of how government works
i was there for longer than my primary
opponent has been there so i've got more
experience than him in that
also i'm a regular guy i'm not from you
know a super super loaded background
so i know what it's like to connect with
regular folks so i think i've got the
best of both worlds there but david i do
have a point i mean you have people who
are narcissistic and this profession
does attract those kind of people and i
myself after our administration was not
planning on going into politics i was in
fact planning on becoming a regular
person again uh you know maybe doing
some work for a think tank or something
and just uh you know getting out of the
spotlight for a bit uh but then some
friends you know for uh
said hey why don't you go back home to
michigan and uh you know take a run
against this peter meyer guy who voted
on p trump and uh it took me a while i
thought about it a lot i prayed about it
i made sure i had my ducks in a row and
ended up diving in a head first to do it
but it's not really necessarily what's
thinking i was kind of looking forward
to being a regular person again so
uh yeah i mean it it does really take
something to drop in here and do this uh
it's very busy you know you're gonna get
attacked and there's long hours and uh
there's scrutiny and things but i do
really think it's worth it because um
you know we need the leadership in there
which is lacking right now so you
mentioned three issues there the first
one was was inflation and and price gas
prices and uh product product prices
that's uh that's something that's
happening globally right now there's a
number of issues there as one of 435
members of congress in the united states
what would you do to deal with the issue
of inflation which is a global one
well it's a global issue to some degree
uh but a lot of this money that's been
printed and the spending that's
happening does have global impact
because the investors take that money
and they invest it all around the world
so i do think um the europeans certainly
have their share of guilt in this for
doing some of the same stuff we're doing
but i think when you look at the kind of
spending and the kind of money printing
that's happening you're getting what's
called the cantillon effect which is
where all this money goes in to the
economy in an efficient way and ends up
driving up prices
in a way that is harmful to regular
folks so
we do have to look at the money printing
and the spending uh which are two of the
critical uh points behind this and david
you have a very good point if i were to
win god willing i'm one of 435. so i
need to form coalitions i need to have
people that are on my side i need to
have the maturity to understand that
everybody that we're in coalition with
won't agree on every issue but john i
hate to interrupt but i really like that
i love talking about policy and we were
i want to stay on that instead of the
coalition
you're talking about money printing now
joe biden's administration did pass this
infrastructure package and that includes
government spending and we could debate
whether it's the type of spending that
you like or that you don't like but the
deficit declined during joe biden's
first year compared to donald trump's
last year in other words spending in
total the the rate at which we overspent
went down in the first year of joe
biden's presidency would you would you
agree with those numbers from the
congressional budget office which is
nonpartisan not the debt now remember i
know you know the difference you're a
harvard guy
the deficit went down in joe biden's
first year do you agree with those
numbers or you dispute them i'll need to
check that because i've actually heard
differing views on that so i'd want to
go back and look up numbers and see if
there's any fuzzy math going on there
as a general rule do you dispute numbers
from the congressional budget office or
is that a fair source in your mind
um i think it's not so much fair or not
it's a matter of there are many ways to
uh to look at these numbers there are
different ways of calculating a deficit
in terms of what you include what don't
you include does it come off the budget
this year or next year or the year after
so i think there's lots of different
ways to slice the pizza here and i need
to look at the way they're doing that to
to make a determination on that would
you agree that at least the
congressional budget office is doing it
the same way every year is that at least
fair they are consistent in how they
measure the deficit
i have to take a look at that again and
they'll talk about their methodology to
uh to see what's the case there but uh
so let me ask you this then if you're
not sure whether we can trust the
numbers of the congressional budget
office what numbers do you have as a
basis to say that the spending is out of
control
oh we can easily look at the amount of
money the government's spending that's a
much simpler
calculation there we can easily look at
inflation uh cpi and whatnot uh those
are pretty standard in the way they're
calculated so
uh we have a pretty good sense of what
those numbers but i think so let's see
but the the problem is you blamed the
spending on the inflation so like for
example in this conversation i'm
agreeing with you inflation has been
high we're 100 on the state there's no
dispute about those numbers
you made the assertion that you believe
the inflation to some degree is because
the spending is out of control i said
typically we look at the congressional
budget office for that and they found
that the deficit was down in joe biden's
first year of the presidency you said
you're not sure if you trust those
numbers and when i asked you well how do
you know spending is up you said well
because i looked at the inflation
numbers but your first claim was the
inflation numbers you believe are
because spending was up but now you're
saying the inflation numbers are the
spending numbers that doesn't make sense
does it it doesn't make sense as high
gas prices that regular people cannot
afford well doesn't make sense is that
black pastures come to me saying people
in our congregation cannot afford to
drive to work because gas prices are too
high what doesn't make sense is that the
price of a pack of chicken or beef or
whatever you're buying at the grocery
store is twice as high that certainly
doesn't make sense and so that's the
problem we're going to solve right we
agree gas prices are high but you made
the assertion that it's because of biden
spending whereas gas prices are up
globally and what i'm trying to do is to
is to make that connection but maybe
maybe we're just not not going to be
able to do that let me ask you a
different question do you agree that
since the peak about two months ago gas
prices are now down about 20 percent do
you dispute those numbers
um what i do know is that gas prices are
still far too high one of the reasons
for that is for example shutting down
the keystone xl pipeline and totally
gutting all efforts to have american
energy independence so we've got to go
back and reverse those policies so that
we can be producing more of our own uh
supply which will bring prices down okay
but so let's so three different things
there you didn't answer my question and
you also made two claims that were wrong
so i'm gonna tr i'm gonna do my best to
keep keep up here so do you agree gas
prices are down about 20 percent from
their peak two months ago
um what i agree on is that gas prices
are slightly higher than they were uh
when joe biden came in office and we got
to fix this problem and bring it back
down do you dispute that the gas prices
are down 20 percent
um
what i dispute is that uh gas prices are
good they're not good they're still too
high okay that's fair let's so the first
5 10 15 20 whatever one might be is
still too high that's the point fair so
now see john you do not really care if
it's down 20 over the past couple of
months whatever but what i do care about
is way higher than it needs to be
so you made an assertion and i agree see
i'm i can very simply agree with you
you're right they're still too high so
you have see how i'm very simply
agreeing with you
are you disputing just that they've come
down 20 or do or do you agree that they
have
um i try to spend time on the relevant
questions when i look at my policy and
the relevant issue here is we got to
bring the gas prices down how do you
know they have to come down more if you
won't even concede they're down 20 how
do you even know what they are
i know that they're way higher than they
were when biden got in there we got to
fix that problem okay so it's it's not
sounding like you're willing to even in
good faith concede they're down 20 can
you tell me why
um i can tell you that i care about high
gas prices because it affects everybody
especially those who are poor in working
class in the middle class as well right
i agree with you you're down i agree
with you but do you seem to be unable to
agree with me on just basic facts it's
weird okay um
i'm finding myself at a bit of a log jam
because we seem to not even be able to
agree on the kind of basic facts let's
try a different topic altogether and see
if maybe we can make some headway
who's the president of the united states
right now
um joe biden is certainly the sitting
president but it looks like president
trump likely won the election um here's
a couple of factory david one uh
president trump got more votes the
second time they got the first time
there's no such thing in american
history of a president getting more
votes the second time and then losing
doesn't exist
the second thing we know that's a fact
is president trump won the bellwether
counties and when he went to bellwether
county you win the presidency with 100
predictability president trump won those
yet still lost both of those are
mathematically impossible so that seems
to indicate very strongly that there is
some
irregularities in the election results
so
you know people are concerned about this
rightfully so and so we really got to
the bottom of it as well as uh increase
our election integrity going forward if
we don't have secure elections we don't
have fair elections you don't have a
democracy so this is a really big issue
we've got to address right well i agree
with your conclusion we have to have
secure elections you said that something
is an impossibility and and what you
said was an impossibility is if you get
more votes the second time than the
first
historically you win am i understanding
that that assessment
yes that's right okay um have you ever
seen things happen for the first time in
your life john
of course okay and so something happened
for the first time in november of 2020
is that fair to say we'll get to whether
it happened fairly don't let's not jump
ahead but arguably
something happened for the first time in
november of 2020 which is a sitting
president got more votes and still lost
fair it was the first time that that
happened
well there's different categories of
things happen for the first time okay uh
there's getting into a car accident for
the first time okay uh well guess what
other people get in the car accidents
all the time so we know that it's
something that happens
you're talking about getting more votes
the second time you got first time
that's something that never happens and
so that's a different category that's
something that is almost certainly
mathematically impossible okay same
category as other things that happen for
the first time so let me give you an
example of something else during the
trump presidency that happened for the
first time and then let's see if we can
agree and then extrapolate from that
the average approval rating for donald
trump during his four years
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era would would you agree with
that and this is no matter even if you
look at a right-leaning pollster like
rasmussen which had trump higher
still on average trump's approval was
the lowest of any president in the
modern era can we agree on that fact
i might double check that but let's
assume just for argument's sake
let's assume it's fair enough so my
suggestion to you as a thinking man
well-educated everything we're talking a
high level here
given that trump's polling
was the lowest of any president in the
modern era which had never it was
unprecedented low
isn't it also possible that you would
see an unprecedented result in the
election is that possible is it possible
theoretically
no it's not possible for a president to
get 20 more votes than they got the
first time than still lose you know but
you didn't you didn't answer the
question though got 3.5 million less
votes the second time the first time he
still won okay so you're really looking
at just pure impossibilities here
i'm not so you're saying that
there's lots of things that happened for
the first time during the trump
presidency but this one thing trump
getting more votes and losing that one's
not possible
that's correct because like i said the
different categories of things that
happen for the first time wow yeah
there's some things happening for the
first time that are plausible there are
some that are not
why haven't any courts found any merit
to the 63 different 2020 election
related complaints that have been
brought to them many of them trump
appointed judges why why is it
because democrats have their legal game
going in a really good way i must say
even though what they're working for was
not good um they had people like mark
elias in charge of it and they did a
good job of it rsi was slow to react
still to respond and did not take this
issue seriously enough before the
election that's just a sad fact i wish
it weren't true so that's answer your
question there but if there were merit
wouldn't a trump appointed judge say
there's merit here let's proceed
well you know if you look at our side
leading up to the election when it comes
to election integrity yeah prepare well
enough uh that's just a sad fact of it
so how could you have been more prepared
there was an army of hundreds of lawyers
and trump said for six months it was
going to be rigged how could they how
could you have been what could have been
done to be more prepared
um a whole lot more you need to have
action at the state level you need to
have litigation they did
watching there was not nearly enough of
that going on either poll watchers need
that poll challengers signed up
uh look in virginia for example at
governor johnson's election yeah
typically in an election in virginia
republicans have coverage at twenty
percent of the precincts as poll
watchers okay but when governor younken
won republicans had 90 coverage at the
precincts that's a concrete example of
something that the republicans did that
was smart and that made an impact on the
election and what i'm saying and i'm
suggesting here is that we didn't have
enough of that leading up to the 2020
election which is why you saw some of
the results you did and that carries
over david as well to the legal issues
um where there is not enough uh
preparation very sadly so um yeah i
think uh we've got to bring our a game
next time you know it's weird because
everybody who is saying that this was a
mathematical impossibility so i'm
hearing you say it i don't know if
you're familiar who mike lindell is he
sells pillows on television i don't know
if you've heard of him i've heard of him
yes yeah he says it's a mathematical
impossibility
sometimes lawyers who have no training
in mathematics say it's a mathematical
impossibility but then you go to actual
statisticians and they say there's
nothing here that raises any red flags
whatsoever
do you think there's some reason why
it's non-mathematicians that are
convinced about the mathematical
impossibility i'm trying to figure that
out
um i would bet that if you ask
mathematicians you will find that they
will say these are highly irregular
numbers um especially the two cases i
cited you so um i believe that there are
many who would admit that these numbers
are impossible
okay
um when it comes to
your platform if you were lucky enough
to win in 2022 and i know you've got to
run in a couple minutes so we'll kind of
end on this note
uh
what would be your goal with regard to
what is being threatened as an
impeachment of joe biden if republicans
take the house and you win
do you think that that's something that
the house of representatives should
prioritize the way congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene and lauren bobert
and others have said
if the evidence of the evidence warrants
it absolutely if the evidence says um
the policies of the biden administration
deliberately have hurt millions of
people um with recklessness and
carelessness um if we determine that
then yes it would be appropriate do you
have any specific policy right now that
you suspect might meet that threshold i
think one you've got to look at the
covert response um there'd be an
investigation there uh two you've got to
look at the afghanistan withdrawal which
got americans killed
and there's also the possibility of
looking at ukraine as well and the
absolute
lack of leadership uh that's being shown
right now those are some possibilities
and as we dig into those if we find out
that there are high crimes and
misdemeanors then those need to be
pursued so you're open i know you're
saying you're not saying for sure but
you might
support impeaching joe biden
for his response to russia's invasion of
ukraine did i hear that correctly
um if there's evidence that american
weakness has led to deaths especially
with americans which is not as much an
issue in ukraine but more in afghanistan
as well as on the southern border
frankly the whole southern border
situation which is human trafficking um
uh is is absolutely outrageous so if we
investigate those and we find that there
are high crimes and misdemeanors and yes
you've got a you have a constitutional
obligation
so so the four possible it's four
possible areas of biden impeachment it
was coveted afghanistan ukraine and the
border is that is it just those four are
there more perhaps there could be others
you know we'll take a look at it and see
and if we find that there are high
crimes of misdemeanors then we will go
to the next step wow wow
uh john gibbs john gibbs is running as a
republican he's running to unseat
congressman peter meyer that's a silent
j as we we now all know
uh john i really appreciate your time
today it's quite an eye-opening uh
platform and i look forward to following
your campaign
thank you david i really appreciate it
thanks for having me on
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
another element of propaganda that we're
hearing from the anti-choice right in
the wake of this leaked decision from
the supreme court that is believed will
overturn roe v wade and planned
parenthood v casey essentially
eliminating the general
understood federal right to an abortion
in most cases for women one of the
things we're hearing from the right is
that this isn't going to go any further
it shouldn't be interpreted that this
change to precedent
ending abortion rights as a federal
issue
should connect to absolutely any other
issue now i don't believe that for a
second and in fact yesterday i tweeted
quote some of the people against
abortion are also against gay marriage
they're against gay adoption they're
against interracial marriage they're
against divorce
some are in favor of it being legal to
fire people for their uh sexual
orientation or gender identity which is
already legal in many states this won't
stop here for sure
there are more people coming around to
this perspective there's a very good
article in esquire written by charlie
pierce
called they're coming for griswold and
obergefell and lawrence and loving and
these are decisions that relate to gay
marriage and interracial marriage and
other things and he says don't for a
second believe what alito put in that
um uh or rather this this is from um i'm
sorry this this is from antonin scalia
we emphasize our decision concerns the
constitutional
right to abort hold on who wrote this
you want to see this is reassurance ah
this is from alito we emphasize our
decision concerns the constitutional
right to abortion and no other right
nothing in this opinion should be
understood to cast doubt on precedents
that do not concern abortion and charlie
pierce writes god above what a croc
they're coming for griswold and for
obergefell and for lawrence and for
loving for all i know there is no reason
to believe that they're not coming for
those things and why do i say that well
i mean just look just just look at this
these are justices all of them alito
barrett gorsuch kavanaugh we looked at
their confirmation hearings yesterday
and when they were asked about roe v
wade they said listen
they do their standard thing
i i can't prejudge i might be in a
situation where i have to you know all
that stuff but
but
i respect precedent and yet here they
are all voting to overturn precedent we
can't trust them as far as we can throw
them and we're already starting to see
an inkling of this among the right one
such example is this guy charlie kirk
who said
if we can get roe v wade overturned
anything is possible you don't stop
after a major win you try to get another
one
hello everybody welcome back email us
your thoughts freedom charlie kirk.com i
have so many other thoughts to kind of
unpack here but i want to kind of get to
one in particular which is
if we're trying to save the country
which we are
and we're looking at
repealing roe versus wade it changes the
entire game
there'll be obviously extraordinary
blowbic black on this unlike anything i
think we've ever seen but this takes
courage simple courage by the five
justices if they do
what they're signaling and that's
something that's in short supply right
now from our leaders
it's kind of like oil coming above
surface it's a sign that there's likely
more below
boy is courage in short supply but i
think there's more than we put we even
can put our eyes on right now and if we
can get roe versus wade overturned
anything
is possible
i want to tell you guys about hillsdale
college yeah so i don't care about
hillsdale college but
uh
this is
not going to be the end
and uh it could be
contraception as part of obamacare that
they go for
you know when we say interracial
marriage i think that that's pretty far
down the line i don't i don't think that
that's next but gay marriage is is a
reasonable target contraception is a
reasonable target
uh a lot of these things are going to be
targets when you get your big i mean
think back think back to maybe one of
the greatest basketball teams in history
the chicago bulls
of the 1990s you know they won those
first three championships and then
jordan retired and then it was like this
is as far as we go even though we're the
best
but they didn't end there
they had to come back and keep going and
they got three more and i don't find
anything equivalent morally between
people like charlie kirk and the great
jordan and scottie pippen arables of the
1990s but in all seriousness you don't
stop after you get a major win you
actually keep going and that's very very
scary stuff we don't usually do
entertainment stories on this show but i
do want to talk about something that
happened last night comedian dave
chappelle was attacked on stage
by an individual believed to be armed
while performing at the la hollywood
bowl
there are a number of different videos
from audience members cell phones which
started to flood social media
and they showed a man a man appear to
run onto stage the stage and tackle
dave chappelle
lapd told cbs la that it was a 23 year
old man armed with a replica handgun
that contained a knife blade arrested
and accused of assault with a deadly
weapon
police identified him as isaiah lee
we're holding him on thirty thousand
dollars bail dave chappelle reportedly
not injured in the attack we're not
gonna show a picture of the attacker
being brought out his arm uh is
completely mangled as a result of how he
was handled by security
and uh that type of imagery is is not
allowed on many of our platforms um
there is a joke
that was made by chris rock now this is
just sort of a strange random thing
chris rock who was slapped by will smith
at the oscars recently was in attendance
and he came up and uh told the following
joke after the incident
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so people having a good time with
that um so why am i talking about this
listen
we cannot have a culture where this is
okay
all right now
initially
it was sort of like uh
asserted without evidence that the
attacker was a trans man attacking dave
chappelle
for chappelle's recently controversial
comments on transgenderism in a netflix
special that that has not been
demonstrated right now
and if it was asserted without evidence
and it puts the spotlight on trans
people who may have nothing to do with
this and even if this was a trans person
to group trans people under what one
person did that's that's absolutely
terrible if that happened okay but we
can't have a culture where it is even
remotely acceptable to do this now i'm
not saying we do
people were
mostly booing this individual they were
supportive of dave chappelle people
mostly have not been supportive of will
smith slapping chris rock
but this is the type of thing where
violence begets violence
and then it creates the need for you
know even more security
at sporting events the same thing has
been going on there was a recent nba
game i apologize i don't have the
details it might have been the milwaukee
bucks i'm not sure
where people were running onto the court
and i think there might have been some
animal rights connection related to the
owner of the team or
i don't have the details but it's this
sort of thing where people were showing
up and to demonstrate against the owner
they were running onto the court and
trying to approach players and then so
you see even more security and then you
see even rougher treatment of people who
uh attempt to enter the field of play
we are seeing people being assaulted
for saying things that others don't like
now i want to make a a clear line here
i am sensitive to the idea
that
sometimes there are forms of speech that
are violent towards groups of people
okay so you can make the case that
banning abortion which is a legislative
act that a state can do this has been a
it's a big topic so i'm choosing this
one you could say banning abortion is a
form of violence against women i'm
sensitive to that i am absolutely
sensitive to that
uh but we're not going to solve it
by showing up and attacking the
legislators we're going to solve it by
voting all of them out putting in
legislators that will legalize abortion
that's the path forward and we could
always say yeah but the the but it's
gerrymandering and it's stacked against
us well then we got to fix that i have
not seen evidence that just physically
attacking the individuals who say the
things we don't like is an acceptable
means of change and i recognize the
difference between
the action of banning abortion versus
dave chappelle saying something in a
special people don't like those are two
different things i don't believe
violence is going to be the solution in
either and so we all have to condemn
this stuff we can condemn the things
dave chappelle said
but we also have to condemn the violence
and uh it's it
i don't like the direction that this is
going
and uh i want to hear from you in the
audience uh as to your perspective on
what i think is an unfortunately growing
trend we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
here's a caller who seems to think the
roe v wade stuff is related to satanic
sacrifice it's very weird very sick
hey david it's her math hey don't worry
about this abortion thing uh you guys uh
protecting women's rights you can't even
define a woman this is all about killing
babies and uh the less satanic sacrifice
that uh he loved to do and selling baby
pops
and killing babies in california uh 28
days after they're born now all of that
stuff is untrue i don't know if i have
to mention that but i will two people
are
sick
yeah
so once again you know we saw jesse
dollamore's interviews with some
anti-abortion people at supreme court
the supreme court yesterday now we're
hearing from this guy these are not
really people you can reason with and so
uh we we have to we have to put people
in power who just won't try to pass this
stuff in the first place because you're
not going to convince someone like that
we have a great bonus show for you today
amazon is announcing benefits
in which they will pay for employees who
have to travel to other states for
abortions
okay now this can simultaneously be a pr
move
and a nice thing to do in light of
what's coming from the supreme court
we'll talk about it we will also talk
about how a record four and a half
million americans quit their jobs in
march and what it means and we will also
talk about joe biden's disinformation
board idea which is being likened to
george orwell's ministry of truth all of
those stories on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpackman.com
you can use the coupon code obama obama
right to get a discount off of a
membership at joinedpakman.com please do
and i'll speak to you on the bonus show